However, the standard error changes because it's based on two sample sizes and
two standard deviations. What is this new standard error? In problem set 10
number 10, we saw that if you subtract normally distributed data from other
normally distributed data, we get a new data set. So, here I'm symbolizing
normally distributed data with a mean of mhu sub one. And a standard deviation
of sigma sub one. And we're subtracting normally distributed data with mhu mu
sub two, sigma sub two. We get a new data set that has mean of just the
difference between these two means. But then the standard deviation, is the sum
of the variances, and then the square root. For samples it's roughly the same.
The standard deviation of this new data set, is even bigger than that for each
individual data set. So, we know that this standard deviation of the combined
data sets is greater than the standard deviation of just one of the samples.
because if we square both sides, we get this. And we know that this is true,
because these are the same. And so, therefore if we add the variants of the
second sample on this side, then this side will be bigger than just this.
Similarly, the standard deviation of the combined data sets is bigger than that
for the second sample. You can think about it intuitively, because if we have
two different distributions and then we subtract this data from the other.
There's going to be even more error than what exists in each individual
distribution. Like we might subtract this data value out here, from this one
here. Or we could subtract a data value down here, from a data value here. And
then when we combine them we have a much wider distribution, and this is the
standard deviation. Now again with independent samples, for analyzing the
difference between those means, remember how before with the one standard T
test, our standard error was S divided by root N? Well now we're using this for
S, because it's based on two samples instead of one. So, we can replace this S
with our new one. Then we can re-write this, since both the numerator and
denominator are under the radical sign. We can say it's the same as this, and
finally we can re-write it like this. Now what happens if our tow sample sizes
are different? Then we simply have sample size one for the first treatment, and
the sample size two for the second sample. This is our new standard error for
independence samples. Before, with paired data or dependent samples, we could
simply calculate the difference between each value for each subject. And then
we could calculate the standard deviation. Therefore, before we just had that
one S, but now we have two different samples and they can each be different
sizes. This also changes our degrees of freedom, but it's easy to understand
before we just subtracted 1 from the sample size, well now we subtract one from
each sample size and then add them. Subtract 1 from n1 subtract 1 from n2 and
them, and that's the same as adding the sample sizes. And then subtracting n2
and here's the degrees of freedom we'll use for the rest of this lesson A more
conservative approach when we're not using software is to use the smaller of n1
minus 1 and n2 minus 1. In other words, the smaller of the two degrees of
freedom from the two samples. But for now we'll just use n1 plus n2 minus 2,
because that's what you'll use later.